oscar winner mira savino is starring in
a hilarious new comedy it's called most
guys are losers she plays amy berzins in
this scene amy's husband learns that
their daughter is bringing her boyfriend
home from college for the holiday uh-oh
take a look
she's bringing the guy home
so it's officially serious then
how long have they been dating
how long have they been dating
ask her
are they sleeping in here together what
were you and i doing when we were their
age yeah when we were there age at your
parents house i slept on the couch
and did that succeed in keeping us apart
first on cbs mornings welcome how are
you doing i'm good thank you how are you
i'm good thank you for joining us now
most guys are losers it's based on a
dating advice book that a dad wrote it's
a real book okay it's a real book by the
same name most guys are losers and it it
was written by a gentleman who owned a
series of bars and had the opportunity
to watch guys in action making moves on
unsuspecting young girls and he he
categorizes them and he wrote it for his
daughter to give her like a handbook of
how to avoid the pitfalls of some guy
who was mr wrong
is that what drew you to the role uh
well i just it's a very charming story
it's quite funny and my character has a
lot of feistiness to her she's like a
mama bear who really loves all her kids
but she's also got her own
spark still i think she's she's a fun
person but you also check him you know
you also check your husband when you
think he's out of line i i looked at
your character mira you seem to be the
glue that sort of held the family
together because it gives you a lot of
laughs but there's also some serious
scenes about
most guys are losers let's just start
with that title for a second everyone i
like the title do you i do
sorry
i don't think it's true but i do like i
think the title is catchy i think the
title is very think of it from a
father's perspective yes perspective no
i have a young daughter you are one of
those moments
so i get it okay so if you're like
looking at a group of guys would you
think that most of them would be good
enough for her
but there are some good men out there
that's the point of the story and that's
the the andy buckley who is so wonderful
in the role as the dad can't see the
good guy for who he is because he's so
primed to judge everybody and block his
daughter from ending up with the wrong
guy
yeah then there's scenes because her dad
is in a pulse arena we saw him in a
couple of scenes is it tough or
difficult working with your dad because
and he also he's plays her dad in the in
the in the movie yeah and at one point
he gives a toast is it tough or is it
fun working with it oh always fun always
fun yeah yeah i know it was lovely and
you mentioned your character is somewhat
of a mama bear with a little bit of
feistiness you're also a mom mother of
four yes um so what advice or you give
mira yeah yeah
what's the end range from what to what
i'm curious
my eldest daughter is 17 and a half she
just graduated from high school i've got
a 16 year old boy like super baseball
player yeah 12 13 year old just turned
13 year old boy also baseball player and
my 10 year old sweetie lucia
um yeah so i'm curious yeah as two moms
um what what is your advice to your kids
18 and 16. soon to be 18 your daughter
and 16 year old and i also want to know
what was your advice to your kids when
they were younger my advice was do not
have sex in high school wait till you're
in college and you're in love now that
was my sex talk and kirby goes i don't
remember having a sex talk sex talk was
don't have sex
maybe that's not really a fact
what was your dating what is your dating
advice i mean i think to find people
that treat them well and not to accept
any pressure you know in that you know
physical realm right um you know they
can wait as long as you know waiting is
better and uh but just just to be with
people that treat them well
and
someone someone once told me when i was
young and dating you know if it's not
right it's wrong yeah and if you're not
happy more than 75 or 80 of the time if
you're not happy that much of the time
it's the wrong relationship you
shouldn't be fighting right it's wrong
in a dating relationship i mean you know
long-term relationships you know real
life problems can arise but when you're
there both of you kind of optionally it
should
don't have sex in high school but that's
a good one too
i actually do think that's a good thing
i meant that too romy and michelle are
you game four it's 25 years uh-oh
you speaking over it what's going on
i i can't say anything but we are closer
now than we've ever been to that being a
reality it actually the wheels are
starting to move and we'll take i am so
excited